in terms of you know what makes a good
uh pickup and drop off location uh we
get really valuable feedback yeah
and in fact we had to um uh do some
really interesting work with a high
definition
maps and uh thinking about walking
directions
if you imagine you're in a store right
in some giant space and then you know
you want to be picked up somewhere like
if you just drop a pin in the current
location which is maybe in the middle of
a shopping mall like what's the best
location for the car to come pick you up
and you can have simple heuristics where
you just kind of take your you know your
cleaning distance uh and find the
nearest
uh spot where the car can't pull over
that's closest to you but oftentimes
it's not the most convenient one you
know i have many anecdotes where that
heuristic
breaks in horrible ways i one example uh
that i often mention is uh somebody
wanted to be
you know uh uh dropped off uh in
phoenix uh and you know we car picked a
location
uh that was close the closest to their
you know where the pin was dropped
uh on the map in terms of you know
latitude and longitude uh but it
happened to be
on the other side of a parking lot that
had this row of cacti
and poor person had to like walk all
around the parking lot to get to where
they wanted to be in 110 degree heat
so that you know that was about so then
you know we took all take all of these
um
all that feedback from our users and uh
incorporate it into our system and yeah
and improve it yeah i feel like that's
like requires
agi to solve the problem of like when
you're which is a very common case when
you're in a big space of some kind
like apartment building it doesn't
matter it's not some large space
and then you call the like the waymo
from there
right like any whatever doesn't matter
rideshare
vehicle and like where is the pin
supposed to drop i feel like that's i
you don't think i think that requires
agi i'm gonna
in order to solve okay the alternative
which i think the google search engine
has taught
is like there's something really
valuable about
the perhaps slightly dumb answer but a
really powerful one which is like
what was done in the past by others like
what was the choice made by others
that seems to be like in terms of google
search when you have like billions of
searches
that you can you could see which like
when they recommend
what you might possibly mean they
suggest based on
not some machine learning thing which
they also do but like on what
was successful for others in the past
and finding a thing that they were happy
with
is that integrated at all with waymo
like
what what pickups worked for others it
is
i i think you're exactly right so
there's uh real it's an interesting
problem
uh naive solutions
have interesting failure modes
so there's definitely lots of things
that can be done to improve
and both learning from
you know what works what doesn't work in
actual hail from you know getting richer
data and
getting more information about the
environment and you know uh
richer maps but you're absolutely right
that there's something and there's some
properties of solutions
that uh in terms of the effect that they
have on the users so much much much much
better than others right and
predictability
and understandability is important so
you can have maybe something that is not
quite as optimal but
is very natural and predictable to the
user and kind of works the same way
all the time and that matters that
matters a lot for the user experience
and but you know to get to the basics
the
pretty fundamental property is that the
car
actually arrives where you told it right
like you can always you know change it
see it on the map and you can move it
around if you don't like it
and but like that property that the car
actually shows up reliably
yeah is critical which you know where uh
compared to some of the human
uh driven yes analogs i think you know
you can have
more unpredictability it's actually uh
the fact uh if if
i have might do a little bit of a detail
here uh i think the fact that
it's you know your phone and the cars
two computers talking to each other
can lead to some really interesting
things we can do in terms of the user
interfaces
both in terms of function like the car
actually shows up exactly where you told
it
uh you want it to be but also some you
know really interesting things on the
user interface right as the car is
driving as you you know call it
and it's on the way to come and pick you
up and of course you get the position of
the car
and the route on the map uh but and they
actually follow that route of course
uh but it can also share some really
interesting information about what it's
doing
so uh you know our cars uh as
they are coming to pick you up if it's
come if a car is coming up to a stop
sign
it will actually show you that like it's
there sitting because it's at a stop
sign or a traffic light it'll show you
that it's got you know sitting at a red
light
so you know they're like little things
uh right uh but
it i find those little touch uh touches
uh
really interesting really magical
and it's just you know little things
like that that you can do to kind of
delight your users
you